the two biggest life hacks that I've had  for being productive that I still do  number one I wake up early and I start  working pretty much immediately I'm not  transiting anywhere I'm not getting  ready I mean from the time my eyes are  open to the time I'm working it's  probably 45 minutes and the second one  is that I just don't schedule anything  before lunch we're pretty Vigilant about  that even with all the demands of time  and all that stuff I have until  basically 12 30 every day that I don't  take really any meetings if I start  working at 5 30 and I have until 12 30.  I have a full work day completely  uninterrupted every day before I do  things like this